when The Handmaid's Tale premiered on
Hulu you might have noticed quite a few
familiar faces including Yvonne
Strahovski who plays her in a joy
if you're wondering we've seen Straub
skew before well you're in luck we put
together a list of her most visible
roles over the years jack for five years
Strahovski played CIA agent Kara Walker
on the NBC action spy comedy Chuck agent
Walker is one of the agents assigned to
protect Chuck after he accidentally
downloads secret government information
into his brain while her primary mission
was to keep Chuck safe from the rogue
groups trying to capture him her cover
as Chuck's girlfriend eventually became
the real deal Strahovski x' character on
chuck was a fan favorite and she went on
to win both a Teen Choice Award and to
TV Guide Awards for her work
Mass Effect Strahovski first lent her
bleach to the character of Miranda
Lawson in the mobile spin-off game Mass
Effect galaxy then hid the video game
franchise full-time in Mass Effect 2 and
the follow-up Mass Effect 3 but she
provided more than a voice for the
character
Miranda was actually designed to look
like Strahovski they scanned my face
into it and and then they made me
brunette and then the body's not mine
the body is not mine Strahovski was
nominated for a Spike Video Game Awards
for her role was Dwarfs in' and lawson
has frequently been included in hottest
video game character list if that Mass
Effect movie project can ever get off
the ground
his hoping Strahovski will be back
killer relief after years of acting
mostly on TV Yvonne Strahovski landed
one of her first big film roles with
2011 Killer Elite where she starred as
Jason Statham's love interest their
attempt to start a bromance runs into a
few roadblocks along the way however and
they both get caught up in a deadly game
of cat and mouse with international
killers killer alley was in a massive
head with critics but it showcased
Strahovski acting abilities and primed
her career the even bigger roles to come
the guilt trip in a twist on the
traditional roadtrip movie the guilt
trip chronicles the cross-country
adventure of Joyce and her adult son
Andy played by Barbra Streisand and Seth
Rogen along the way of course to
discover a lot more about themselves
than they planned you're born Strahovski
plays a small but memorable role is one
of Andy's old girlfriends who rescues
them when their cars break down well
it's a relatively small part Strahovski
definitely helps try to intern before
quit up to 11 during this
cringe-inducing scene
Dexter showtimes serial killer drama
Dexter ran for eight seasons and one of
the highlights of the last two of those
seasons was the introduction of Hannah
McKay played by Strahovski a woman with
secrets just as dark as Dexter's
Mackay's complicated romantic
relationship with Dexter evolves until
the final episode and eventually comes
to a head as the two killers attempt to
flee the country together we're not sure
how many real relationships start with
attempted murder but on Dexter what else
would you expect 24 live another day
although Strahovski played a CIA agent
in both Chuck and 24 the character of
Kate Morgan couldn't be more different
from the light-hearted role of Sarah
Walker and chart in 24th live another
day Morgan is the widow of another CIA
agent who committed suicide after he was
accused of treason through to the show
style Kate Morgan is a gritty serious
character who doesn't pull any punches
as she ruthlessly tracks down Jack Bauer
and works to uncover his true motives
along the way she learns the shocking
truth behind a husband's alleged treason
I Frankenstein
this action fantasy film drops the
reanimated monster of Victor
Frankenstein into an epic struggle
between good and evil that makes its way
to the modern day caught in the middle
of the conflict is Yvonne Strahovski
character Cara a scientist conducting
experiments on reanimations than
Naberius
played by Bill Nighy not realising his
true nature as a demon Frankenstein's
monster must do his best to not only
defeat Naberius
and foil his plans but also save Carole
well the demon Prince can use her to
create an army of undead the astronaut
Wives Club this ABC miniseries ad in
2015 and chronicled the lives of the
wives of the mercury 7 America's first
astronauts said during NASA's most
tumultuous period the show covers
everything from the first manned
American flight in space to the first
moon landing while obviously dramatized
the television it's an intriguing look
at women thrust into the spotlight
simply because of who they were married
to Strahovski co-stars as Renee
carpenter wife of scott Carpenter who
flew in the second orbital mission
Manhattan died in this crime drama from
2016 Strahovski pairs up with Adrien
Brody who plays Porter a crime reporter
in New York City the pair start an
illicit romance when Strahovski
character Caroline contacts him to
uncover information about a husband's
recent mysterious death soon they find
themselves caught up in mystery bigger
than they'd imagined Manhattan ID is a
stylish modern gwad that didn't make any
big waves on its release but it showed
off Strahovski is acting range and now
that she's co-starring in Hulu's hit
series The Handmaid's Tale there's no
telling where your bond Strahovski is
career will go next thanks for watching
click the blue icon subscribe to our
youtube channel plus check out all this
cool stuff we know you'll love to
[Applause]
you